hello everyone I'm making this video
specifically targeted at the parents of
those children who are currently
studying in high school meaning starting
from standard 6th or 7th to class 10
this is not meant for the parents of
those children who are currently in plus
two
already so greetings parents uh in this
video I'm going to spell out a certain
uh number of things which may not be
quite Pleasant to hear but I think which
are important to point out I also would
like to uh say beforehand that I know
that all of you parents of children who
are in high school are senior to me you
are more experienced in life compared to
me but what I'm going to say is kind of
a constructive criticism from the point
of view of a person who has been uh
involved in teaching students who are in
their late teens to their early 20s so
kindly take this in the proper spirit so
let us get into the actual discussion as
you all know this is December 2023 and
like every year this is the period where
uh the placement season is going on at
the various engineering
institutes and just like every year news
must be percolating in that so and so
student has got one CR package two CR
package and this is the kind of news uh
which kind of um comes without the
proper context like what is the actual
meaning of this one CR or two CR package
or actually how many students end up in
that extremely high tier of packages uh
without this context this news this kind
of news comes and every year many
parents are taken in by this news uh and
they start spinning dreams of a very
high life for their own children for
their own families B based on this kind
of news and what happens is that that
they send their children uh as early as
standard 6th or 7th to the coaching
institutes thinking that such a dream
will also be true for them that the
dream of that one CR or two CR package
or maybe even
more and this is problematic and this is
the issue which I want to discuss today
uh this is problematic because what
happens is that this coaching is more
like a business
investment now as in any kind of
business investment you as the investor
would like to get a return of investment
but unlike an actual business investment
where your money is doing the hard work
so to speak here the hard work and all
the all the turmoils all the risks will
have to be born by your children
children so think about it a little bit
now this is where the problem really
begins because your children understand
that this is an investment through
them and this investment the the work of
bringing in the return of this
investment it starts from their early
days of high school and so you see it is
almost like 10 years of work towards
realizing the dream of getting the
return of that investment how it is so
so see around four years 3 to 4 years of
high school up to class 10 then 2 years
of that intense pressure in the plus two
level the senior secondary level or
higher secondary level and then another
four to 5 years in the colleges so in
total almost a decade of the brightest
years of this of their life this
children's life is geared towards
realizing this dream of getting the
invest the the the return of this
investment now uh what are the problems
that are associated with this so even
before the students start showing some
kind of
abilities in high school that is that is
the time when they start showing some
kind of budding uh abilities even before
they start showing this when their
parents send them off to coaching they
get straight jacketed into a very narrow
kind of a preparation a very narrow kind
of uh like forced flowering of their
abilities which may not be there in the
first
place it is also uh problematic in the
sense that suppose you send them off to
a coaching Institute and uh suppose
let's say for uh I mean in an optimistic
way they show they they perform
reasonably well they adapt themselves to
the coaching Institute
but uh it it doesn't really mean that
they could not have explored some other
opportunities in high school perhaps
they could have done that perhaps they
could have been better at that but the
moment you send them off to the coaching
institutes they are not able to explore
those kinds of hidden abilities at all
that is completely gone that opportunity
is completely
gone so what is the Fallout of of all of
this again let us proceed on this
positive note reasonably positive note
that they keep on performing well they
managed to get into some kind of their
dream Institute perhaps one of the older
IES but as a result of this intense
pressure full situation year after year
that they have gone through after they
come to the iits and this is something
which we as faculty members see each and
every year year after year that
many of these students and I'm I'm
really sorry to say this that many of
the students although they become Ians
at best they become mediocre
Ians it is also true that many students
who have not gone through this kind of
an intense coaching starting from their
very early days of high school maybe
their rank was not that high in IJ in J
but once they come here they start
really flowering and they actually
despite their not so high rank it is
they Who start showing really glimpses
of Brilliance uh uh in the actual
engineering studies this is also very
much true now coming back to those
students who are uh who have uh been
going to this coaching institutes from
very early days it is of course not true
in each and every case but it is true in
many of the cases that uh since they are
in their last leg of their 10year
pressure full Journey because this is
now the last last four years of that
Journey right in the engineering
colleges what happens is that they are
completely kind of worn out burnt out
whatever you like to call it and at the
same time they are experiencing a new
found freedom for the first time in
their lives because the coaching
institutes are extremely regimented the
plus two is like like a race okay it's
like a absolutely cruel race and then
finally after they come they kind of
breathe a sigh of relief and there's a
lot of freedom in the injuring
Institutes and they completely give up
on on any kind of competitiveness they
take it very easy and the irony is that
this is the time where they should not
be taking it easy but it is I mean this
is the sad truth now uh what what also
happens and uh this is going back to the
point of that return of investment is
that once they come to the engineering
institutes they are mature enough to
start realizing by themselves that that
dream of the one CR or two CR package
that is not actually a a reality for
every one of them in fact for the vast
majority of them this is not at all true
so a kind of uh frustrating
disillusionment sets in uh from this
realization because the investment has
already been done the dreams had already
been pinned on their shoulders but now
they realize that this is not going to
happen so so even before they turn 25 by
the time they pass out they're barely
what 22 years old 23 years
old by the time they pass out they are
kind of jaded uh in their in their life
view it is like even before they start
their carers they are in a kind of
retirement uh mentality I mean it's it's
all over now I mean they just coast
along with some kind of a med Yer job or
some kind of a I mean kind of situation
another important point which I would
like to mention here is that many of
these students who are reasonably
successful they uh are very academically
oriented but uh because so much
investment has been already made towards
realizing that dream of an extremely
high package which can can be realized
only if they go to some kind of an
industry some kind of a proper company
job despite their innate interest in
some kind of academic career they have
to refrain from such kind of doing uh
doing so because see if you have to
pursue an academic career then after
your Bachelors you have to go for your
Masters and after your Masters you have
to go for a PhD that's a much longer
time investment without uh without the
financial REM eration which students
otherwise would have obtained had they
joined some kind of a company so because
there's always this pressure of getting
back the investment uh getting back uh I
mean realizing the dream of an extremely
high salary they refrain from going into
an academic career which is never high
paying so this is also a tremendously uh
unfortunate Fallout but what I would
like to point out here is that despite
this Bleak view of things remember that
this this situation is still uh it can
still be counted as a reasonable success
story for the students those who manage
to get into their dream institutes those
who still manage to get some job okay
maybe it's not a one CR two CR package
but it's a reasonably good job good
package they settle down in life I mean
proceed uh maybe not with tremendously
in a tremendously enthusiastic fashion
but they they get along in life so I I
would still count this as a reasonably
success story but on the flip side try
to remember that there were also certain
parents who had made this kind of an
investment of sending their students to
coaching institutes but because of a
number of factors not the least of which
is the fact that this sending off to a
coaching Institute with the expectation
that they will perform outstandingly
well and um the the actual ability
there's a massive disconnect between the
two the abil ities of the students and
these kinds of dreams and hopes and as a
result of which and because of many
other factors also the students end up
not being successful in these various
entrance examinations and year after
year they cling to the shadow of this
dream but never really realize realizing
it properly ultimately ending up in some
kind of not at all good college very
very far off from their original Dream
and at the same time they have lost all
the opportunities that the other kinds
of opportunities which they could have
explored in order to realize some dreams
which would have been their own what I
mean to say here is that they have
basically uh gone around investing those
years the best years of their of their
uh Teenage life uh in trying to realize
the dreams the secondhand dreams of
their parents those dreams were not
theirs to begin with and now they it's
too late for them to maybe invest the
time and and energy to uh to really
flower some of the other abilities which
they could have done had they not gone
off to coaching so early so my request
to you uh as parents is uh is it really
wise to always compare your child
without the the sound basis of first
exploring what abilities he or she has
with other children who may already be
St starting to show some kind of serious
academic abilities uh this kind of an
unfortunate comparison if you keep on
making is this really good for your
children is this really good in a
genuine sense for your
family just try to think of a simple
example the we all know that uh
cricketers I mean
they earn like tremendously high amounts
and they are rich and famous and
everything but many of you are I need
not say this you are already wise enough
to understand that it is it is
strategically not wise to invest time
effort and money serious money into your
child if he or she is not showing some
kind of serious criting ability or for
any other matter maybe uh abilities in
acting or of whatever it is that uh it
is that make makes people rich and
famous you are well aware of this kind
of a situation that it is not wise to do
such kind of a thing so when you know
that there is a serious involvement of
of a certain kind of a very specialized
ability
together with a lot of luck involved it
is not good to invest in those things
then why would you even before ex
realizing that whether the whether your
child has a special kind of an academic
ability or not why do you want to push
him towards coaching I not saying at all
that you should not send him to coaching
maybe in plus two by which time you
would have realized that yes he has some
kind of a special ability maybe he or
she is good in maths and and physics
things like this in at which point it
would make at least some sense to send
them but sending it as early as 6th or
7th when uh when you may not have
realized that that ability exists would
it is it really wise so is this kind of
a uh situation not similar to sending
off your children to some kind of like
expensive Cricket coaching Academy
without even realizing whether he can
bow or
bat try to think about
it so U my very polite I mean request to
you was that first please explore
whether I mean whether your uh child
really wants to go for this kind of
coaching or not whether he or she even
uh I mean probably wants to explore some
other kind of things and
please please for God's sake please do
not compare what your child is showing
right now whether if if or she is in
class five six seven these these early
periods with what other people are uh
with with what other people's children
are doing maybe some children flower a
little bit early they show some buding
talents a little bit early uh so it
would not be wise at all so just think
okay down the line if you make this
investment Without Really uh exploring
this these abilities
your investment will be gone your
child's career will also be gone what
could have been
otherwise so what is the benefit so on
that note on that rather poyant note I
will end this video and I apologize if
my questions had seemed a little bit
rude to you but uh if my questions of my
discussions induces at least some
discussion towards this end I think
it'll be uh some success for this
discussion all right thank you very much
and all the very best to your children
and to your family